[Music]
today machine learning models are fairly
mainstream they are shipping in large
consumer facing projects also in
enterprise projects and that's what we
want to tell you about today for that I
would like to welcome Nick Spearin from
gigster Thank You Martin and I also want
to thank everyone for coming to this
session this is a repeat of our session
on Tuesday just really thank a lot for
coming and a few words about gigster
gigster is a consulting company that
delivers digital transformation and
business impact to enterprises at
startup speed we focus on new technology
AI machine learning in particular I lead
a IML projects and today we will talk
about one particular project that we did
for the leading consumer electronics
company and since this is a technical
conference I will show you this slide we
put Tiger in a box seriously we built
over 20 different models for this client
including image tagging composition
analysis style analysis color analysis
and many others and for this talk we
decided to pick object detection as our
model since it's an exciting model from
the research point of view and also
because it opened a lot of different
applications for the customers and Nick
this is a product that is actually
shipping today a product for
professional photographers correct this
is already actually running nice so tell
us more why object detection why
specifically this object detection as
you can see on the slide by having
bounding boxes we can select images with
a specific object and also in a
particular location so that it allows
for possible overlay of text for example
for media applications or advertisements
also surprisingly for me and the team we
found that photographers do care about
images like that
they call it animal portrait in the same
way as we speak about human portraits
and they do differentiate those images
from animal pictures at the distance and
actively search for such images on the
platform that we also build for the
customer and finally object detection is
a type of model that draws bounding
boxes around objects and because of that
it allows object counting and queries
like two cute pandas while image tagging
or image classification which is the
common application also in the computer
vision space only supports assignment of
binary labels of presence of a
particular object on an image and for
this use case you have from your
customer a data set of over 300,000
images with I think something like
600,000 bounding boxes and the what we
are going to tell you today is how we
took one model or a Tina net how we
train it on TP use to deliver this end
user experience but I would like to do
something a little bit more let's train
this model here on stage let's do it and
we will truly show the power of GPUs for
fast training so I will explain a little
bit more death what I'm doing here all
right just in a second that's what they
talk is about here I just want to launch
the script that will start this training
job so I'm in this one just a second
Here I am let's call it let's call the
model on stage okay
and I'm launching it so it's doing stuff
doing doing stuff and I should have a
job launched right here in a second
the job is launched I'm going to check
in my a ie platform jobs interface that
I have a job running it has been running
for four seconds let's now dive deeper
into what these TP use are tensor
processing units so this is a deep UV -
this is a TPU v3 those are fairly large
boards large like this you have four
chips on one board and each chip is a
dual-core CPU and by the way on the
floor you have a whole rack of those
CPUs looks like this and in Google cloud
you can provision a GPU either by board
eight cores or you can actually get
multiple of those boards together in
what we call a pod and they are tied
together on a high-performance
interconnect that makes them look like
to your application as just one
accelerator so the only work you have to
do is to increase your training batch
size to take advantage of all this
additional hardware Nick between v2 and
v3 which one do you like
short answer v3 and it's not because v3
is the latest version of TPU but because
based on our experiments combining TPU v
3 plus root Internet which we will cover
later it's a model for object detection
TPU v3 was 3.5 times faster compared to
TPU v2 and at the same time CPU v3 is
only twice as more expensive so
combining those two things together they
are why in terms of computation per
dollar for TPU v3 for that particular
training job is better so our
recommendation if you do object
detection use root Internet use TB with
v3
let's have a look at one teepee what is
inside I told you on board for chips
dual core what is in each of those
course so you have a fairly traditional
vector processing unit but the specific
part that makes this special for neural
network workloads is the matrix multiply
unit it's a dedicated hardware unit that
performs 128 by 128 matrix
multiplications and it does so for speed
in reduced float16 precision so this is
a very traditional trick in neural
networks to work in reduced precision
neural network training is fairly
resistant to the loss of precision there
are even cases where the loss of
precision by introducing noise actually
helps the training sometimes you even
introduce noise on purpose as a regular
as a regular as as a way of helping the
the training but the traditional in the
standard float16 format as you can see
here has a different number of exponent
bits compared to float32 which means
that it doesn't have the same range and
so when you pause your model to reduce
precision using float16 you usually get
under flows and overflows so all of
these problems are fixable
if you know your code but it's work and
in tipi use we decided to use a slightly
different reduced precision format which
we call b float16
and you see it's actually float32 with
just the fractional bits cut off it has
exactly the same number of exponent bits
exactly the same range which means that
it's usually a drop-in replacement for
your float32 and there is nothing to be
done on your model when you use that
it's you don't actually don't have to do
the work of using B float16
this is something that is done
automatically you send the the data in
float32 and it goes that it gets
downgraded in the AMEX you
on the input and then the multiplication
between two 16 bits floating point
numbers becomes again a float 32 which
is what the result is
and now how is this unit built the a
mixture so it uses a quite a rare
architecture in in in in microprocessors
called a systolic
array try to remember how to perform a
matrix multiplication so a matrix
multiply each point of the result is a
dot product of one line of a matrix and
one column of the second Matrix and a
dot product is a series of multiply
accumulate operations multiplied plus
multiply plus x plus multiples so the
only compute element we have in this
whole array or multiply accumulate
elements and I think you will have to
spend a little bit more time off line
with this animation but what it does is
that you load one of the arrays into a
wall of one of your matrices into this
array and you flow the numbers from your
second matrix through this array and if
you I mean you'll have to believe me
as as the data flows through it and as
the multiply accumulates are performed
and the intermediate result gets passed
to the right out of this side will come
out all the dot products that compose
your resulting matrix the nice part
about this architecture is well first of
all all the intermediate results are
just flowing on the wire so nothing to
store back to registers or to
intermediate memory or anything else
everything is self-contained in here and
the second thing is that the individual
computer element is a tiny tiny 16 bit
by 16 bit multiply and accumulate unit
which means that we can cram lots of
them in one chip and this 128 by 128
array contains 16 thousand of those
compute units of course it's dual core
so 32 thousand in in total density means
power and power means cost
that's the advantage of GPUs and of
course you want to know how fast this
goes so some of you might remember my
talk from last year when I showed you
how to do a airplane spotting I'm using
this this this neural network as a
benchmark these days and so this neural
network trains is in four and a half
hours on a big powerful GPU on ML engine
ai platform now you can you can easily
get a cluster of those and with five
powerful GPUs I can train this in one
hour and I've chosen this example
because this is exactly the time it
takes to train it on one cloud tip uv2
so just as a rule of thumb one cloud CPU
for chips roughly equivalent to five
powerful GPUs in terms of speed in terms
of cost it's almost three times less
expensive because we have a density
advantage in the microarchitecture so
now we have powerful hardware we also
need a model an object detection model
each we have a whole library of models
TPU optimized models in this github
slash ten through flow such TPU
repository Nick which one did you choose
we picked written Annette obviously
since it's an object detection model and
we also picked written Annette not only
because it is the model available in the
official tensor file wrapper for object
detection but because it is considered
to be one of the best models object
detection in general and lets you can
tell us how it works why is it the best
yeah
first before we go deep into the routine
Annette details I will introduce the
overall pipeline that is used for object
detection and then we will cover special
new idea that was introduced in the
official written annette paper
so overall object detection works as a
pipeline where we first generate a lot
of bounding boxes and you see them on
the slide those
also called proposals and then we do
prediction of the class labels and
adjustment of the positions of the
bounding boxes using the neural net and
there are one stage neural networks and
two stage neural networks in the sense
that in one case for example one shot
neural networks such as overfeed SSD
Yola they combine candidate generation
bounding box generation and detection
stages together they process images only
once and that's why they are fast at the
same time they are not as accurate and
there are two stage detectors which
separate those two stages into two they
first generate candidate proposals but
then they do sampling and
post-processing of the bounding boxes
and then they already predict the class
labels and adjust the coordinates so
retina net was designed to address those
shortcomings and to be both fast and
accurate and it's a one stage attack
that hits a one stage detector and it
uses the ResNet as a backbone and it
also relies on the pyramid structure of
the neural network and the fact that it
has inside pooling layers that gradually
shrink the size of the image and it is
helpful because when we want to do
object detection we want to be able to
recognize objects at different sizes at
different resolutions and by having the
natural structure of the resonate
pyramid we generate multiple layers of
present representation and this is
called feature pyramid Network the idea
that was also introduced in the paper on
future pyramids and we use that
multi-resolution representation
combination of those feature maps of as
our image and then we extend it with two
sub networks one sub network is
responsible for classification and this
is basically to assign class label and
the second part is responsible for
regression where we use special type of
parameterization which was introduced in
faster RC
and paper called anchors so I'll not go
into the details but the idea here is
that we have bounty boxes and we adjust
the coordinates of the bounding boxes
using the neural net and that's the
architecture that we use and obviously
then we launch the training process and
so this architecture actually existed
before it's internet but you told me it
has it has one problem called class
imbalance what's that let's talk about
it a little bit object detection as you
can see on the slide there are only two
pandas and those are true positions of
the bounding boxes around them in red
and there are a lot of background
bounding boxes in blue and those are
negative examples for machine learning
so when you train a neural net the lost
function that you have if you sum over
all potential positions of bounding
boxes they're easy cases or the cases
coming from the background
they will saturate the loss function so
that it will be not sensitive to the
true objective that we try to learn from
the data set how to predict the position
and class label for real bounding boxes
and when you say they are easy
you mean that the network makes a small
error on them but small error multiplied
by hundreds of of background boxes
becomes big error and and the pandas get
lots lost in that in ratima net
introduced a very clever idea to
overcome that called the focal loss
yeah and focal loss just for you to
remember comes from the word focus
because it actually focuses on hard
examples so examples which are difficult
to classify or for the neural net and in
terms of like math it extends the
traditional cross-entropy laws by adding
the multiplication factor 1 minus P to
the power of gamma and then the way it
works essentially if the probability is
high which means that an easy example
then the multiplicative factor will be
very very small especially if we explain
Shadid and the contribution of that easy
example or the background bounding box
will be very very minimal to the loss
function and if it's the opposite then
it will be kept in the loss function and
because of that the neural net will be
really able to learn the important
signal of how to focus on the heart
examples so that's the clever idea but
this actually works in in this in this
picture you have various variants of
retina net in in in color and the the
letters or various competing
architectures and this is a accuracy
versus speed diagram you see that I put
a red line in there for for better
understanding retina net is above
everything yeah and as we say in the
research community it's in their upper
envelop of the of the graph we have good
hardware we have a great model what is
missing now is a good working
environment for data scientists to put
you to put this model through its paces
and for that I would like to show you a
new feature in AI platform which is
called notebooks so AI platform used to
be called ml engine as we are adding
feature we renamed it AI platform you're
used to jobs and deployed models the new
feature here is notebooks in notebooks
you can create a new instance that has
everything installed in either
tensorflow
or pi torch and you can select that you
want it you want just the standard
instance with CPUs or you can get a GP
GP you do with it or even a GPU I'll
show you how in a second what you get is
an instance and a link a fast link to
open Jupiter directly on your instance I
actually I've I've done that that's why
it's complaining so here I am in my
familiar
Jupiter environment and actually in this
environment on this this machine is
actually TPU powered since you have not
seen it in the UI how to
create a Jupiter machine with a GPU let
me give you the cheat code you can do so
on the command line so I have one
command line to launch my VM and the
second one to create a GPU and a little
bit of glue here to connect the two
it will soon be in the UI in the
meantime this is how you can get there
so let's do something in in this
environment let's let's have a look at
at some data first of all I want to show
you how to load data because GPUs are
very fast which means that it's it
happens very quickly that you get data
start and and and you have a limit on
how fast your training simply because
the data is not getting there fast
enough so in here in in this notebook I
have a first cell that loads of the the
annotations of this data set 300
thousand images those are the
annotations all the boxes you see it's a
wildlife specific data set here are all
the categories it can recognize Mouse's
hamsters snow leopards and so on and
what I like about notebooks is that I
can visualize my statistics and eyeball
my data set so for example I see that I
have a couple of fairly large images in
this data set maybe I will have to pay
attention to that but now I want to see
my for my images so for that I'm going
to use the TF dot data dot data set API
that's an API that is designed to
prepare datasets for ingestion by a
neural network I'm starting with here
list files and from a bucket on GCS I'm
getting a data set of file names then in
this API you can map any function on
your data set so I'm mapping a decoding
function which is here it does basically
loads the image and calls decode JPEG
and now for my data set of file names I
have a data set of images in memory I
will also need to map and resize my my
images
and then I have all the tools I need to
work on my data set so I can repeat it
across multiple epochs I can shuffle it
I can batch my data set for training and
one nice one is prefetch with prefetch
you are telling the system to work on
the next batch while you are you are
training on the current batch so you can
do all the pre-processing in parallel
with training with prefetch and in
tensorflow the way you can iterate on a
data set to see what is inside is simply
by creating a loop this works in either
tensorflow 2.0 or if you activate eager
mode in tensorflow and here I am here
either my image tensors coming out so 16
by 16 okay batches of 16 3 2 4 by 3 D 4
images but you see this is painfully
slow and they're coming like one every
second super slow why is that we have
300 thousand images and they are on GCS
GCS can get you great throughput but GCS
has any storage that is attached through
IP the internet will have a penalty for
every file you access so accessing
getting 300,000 files one by one is not
a good idea at all
won't work and yeah I'm visualizing them
so you see what kind of images I have
the the solution is to batch your files
into bigger files and for that the we
use a file format code called TF records
we use it not because it has super
special features but because it's it can
put multiple pieces of data in one file
and it has good support in the in the
data set library so let me show you how
to use it
Nick and his team they've done the work
of putting those files into TF records
so now I'm reading here from a bucket
which has TF record files and it starts
again with list files I have a list of
file names the
I apply I create from that hcf record
dataset now I have a data set of records
this line is commented out because I do
advise you to use this interleaf command
to apply to F record data set because
with this you are reading from 16 files
at once and that is how you get a good
throughput from GCS you put your
your-your-your data into a reasonable
number of reasonably large files like
100 megabytes large and then you read
from multiple files at once using the
data set API
after that I'm mapping a decoding
function which is here and here
basically I'm reading from every records
all the stuff that Nick had posted has
put in there so there is the image some
metadata and all my bounding boxes and
the classes of those banding boxes and
sure that is that's basically it so now
again I can visualize my my my images
and let me a relaunch here a loop that
will pull images 16 by 16 so here is my
training data set you see it has
pictures and bounding boxes dolphins
ladybugs and so on and this time as you
can see my batches of 16 images are
coming out at a steady clip this is the
speed you want and just pause here for a
second this is one design pattern or
like programmed pattern that we want you
to remember to have a reasonable number
of reasonably large files reasonable
number of files is about 110 to 110 to
109 bytes in this case you will be able
to really maximize the throughput and
benefit from TF the data the data set
parallel loading one additional tip that
we want to share is about the bounding
boxes and the nuances of the written net
implementation especially for the data
scientists in the room for managers it's
just like hard and data scientists
should be valued
there was a cabinet in the
implementation of retina net from the
official repa
where there was a limit on the number of
bounding boxes to 100 somewhere hidden
in the court we started we thought that
it will just work off the bat and it was
silently you know stopping and training
was failing and the practical suggestion
for you is to filter out the bounding
boxes from the images if it's not very
critical for your application so you
have an image either you skip it for you
or you remove them the number of
bounding boxes per image so that this
pipeline can be used obviously if you
really want to build a detector that is
capturing a lot of different objects for
example it could be people tracking for
security applications then you have to
work around on that but a short fix is
know at least that there are 100
bounding boxes in the implementation as
a hard setting I also want you to want
to show you how to use a GPU with your
own chaos model so well that let me use
the exact same data set but I have just
taken one the first class for every
image and I will build a very simple
classifier just to show you how to build
a chaos model using a TPU so same data
set you recognize the data set code here
and the the second piece of the code is
here a convolutional classifier a set in
chaos so it uses the TF dot character
sequential model and it's a sequence of
convolutional layers ending with a
certain number of classes of my softmax
activation so it's a classifier here is
what care what carest tells me this
model is made of and the three lines of
code that I would like to show you are
here first you have one function to find
your TPU then there is a second function
to define a TPU distribution strategy
using that TPU y distribution one TPU is
eight cores
it's so it's it's distributed training
and a third function that transforms
your chaos model into a model that can
be trained on GPU so those three the
three lines allow you to use TP use in
chaos and if I run them you will see
here in the in the logs that my H TPU
cores are showing up this notebook is
actually powered by ATP v3 and then I
can launch the training well there is
there will be nothing interesting here
normal chaos training will start it
takes just a couple of seconds to start
I think that we can we can move on
because we have other interesting things
to tell you
yeah here you see it started so just to
recap this is how you use TP use in a
chaos model three simple lines find your
GP you define a distribution strategy
that uses that GPU and then Kerris to
GPU model to get a model that you can
train and when you train it it will run
on GPU
a quick word of what is going on so this
is your VM your tensorflow Python code
that's what it's running you remember
that Python and Kara's they represent
your neural network as a computation
graph in memory and it's that
computation graph that is sent to the
GPU your GPU never sees your Python code
that's important you have to bear in
mind the GPUs they don't execute Python
code they get that computation graph
they use the accelerated linear algebra
compiler xla to transform that
computation graph into GPU byte code and
if you are using the data set api then
your data input pipeline is also a piece
of dental floss graph which will be
shipped to the GPU and during training
the GPU will be pulling data directly
from GCS so that's quite efficient and
then finally this is the code for
reading from chef records files please
don't if you don't care about ordering
of your data which you never do usually
shuffle your data please don't forget to
put experimental deterministic equals
false
because this tells the data set API that
it can do whatever it wants with the
data to get it fast and then you list
your files you from a data set of file
names you get a data set of records your
map a decoding function to get a data
set of whatever you care about and then
you can shuffle batch repeat prefetch
your data and also please use the
interleaf function to apply your to your
TF record data set transformation
because that's how you can load your
data from sixteen files at once so Nick
how do you like having a powerful TPU v3
at your fingertips in a notebook I think
having a powerful accelerator is
definitely amazing at the same time we
don't want to pay for powerful machines
just to type code and we also don't want
to run around and chase machines that
are idle and don't do any useful work
because we have to pay for it and how
did you solve that problem at kik sir
yeah when we started we were ahead of
the game and we had to invent some
solutions from scratch
and we built so-called thing G de which
is gigster development environment and
set of processes around it to make sure
that our data scientists on the team are
productive and also that we minimize the
infrastructure cost the way it works we
have a few machines allocated to the
team for quick interactive experiments
and we also have the daughter ice jobs
that we start for training real
production work models so we have a lot
of terraform scripts ansible scripts
that provision the machines install
necessary you know environment variables
drivers and so on and then take docker
container run the job out of the docker
container and save the model to the
cloud storage and that took us a lot of
effort to build and it would be nice if
it comes out of the box or almost out of
the bottle yes NC bolt have farm scripts
that doesn't sound like data science
does it yeah it's not that science it's
DevOps we have a a great set of DevOps
engineers but yes I would like to show
you a new EP API that just came out
where a data scientist can that a data
scientist can use to launch his notebook
as a job without doing a lot of work
it's called fairing and that's what I
used at the beginning to launch my job
and now let me show you exactly what it
is
so first of all this is my fearing is is
the cap of a rocket okay it's where you
put the payloads so that's the idea you
have a payload and you want to launch
this payload as a job so that you don't
have to worry about the infrastructure
it will spin up the infrastructure which
will tear it down at the end what is my
payload so here is my payload it's a
notebook looks very much like the
previous notebook I I showed you and
sure let's call this one on stage two
what what it does is that well it does
some exploratory analysis of the data
set it maybe it displays a couple of
images then I have a training cell and
then when the model my model has trained
I have an inference cell that does
something with the train model that's
very typical of the way I use notebooks
to work on models but now my model is in
a fairly good shape I want to launch its
training as a job and usually you don't
want to do this once you will going to
launch it once with this parameter and a
second time with this parameter and then
the fourth and fifth time and very
quickly you have multiple jobs running
which is something you would not be able
to do on one Jupiter machine so this is
the fairing API it has three components
the first one is to know what is what
are the requirements of your job for
that the easiest is to have a docker
file describing the environment I was
kind of scared of that it's not my world
but my colleague showed me that the
docker file was basically these four
lines listing the
PIPP installs that I needed to do okay I
can write this and then the fearing API
itself has those three calls
so one call set builder to specify what
is your base environment the docker file
from which it will be building your job
a second one set deployer here I'm
saying GC p GC p means AI platform a job
on AI platform and I can specify here
what kind of hardware I want you see
here I'm asking for a TPU v3 TP v3 and
finally a third line specifying what is
the payload one option is to have a full
notebook of course if it is just Python
scripts that works just as well but if
I'm selecting a full notebook I can
specify my notebook file and if I have
any number of sidecar files that I need
for example here my retina net Python
files I can specify a list of those and
then where I want to put my output when
I run this what happens is that all
these things get packaged into
automatically into another docker
container and a job is launched on a a
platform jobs using that docker
container what is it here it started let
me check that in my jobs now I have a
second job running launch four seconds
ago so I can stop this one I don't need
it I already don't launch it at the
beginning and maybe we can check if our
bottle has finished training so let's
see
I should have here right here
I have this folder on stage healed it
has finished training this numbers
folder contains a saved model so let's
see what whatever this model looks like
I mean I need to download this I'm going
to upload it here so that we can see it
downloads on stage ok it's coming up it
will take a little minute to upload see
if I do this it tells me it hasn't
finished so what I want to show you here
is that the result of my job usually
when I want a job from a notebook I have
to extract some code from my notebook
and and then I lose my nice environment
which I'm used to here the result of the
job is a fully rendered notebook so
everything I have before training
playing with the data all the
visualizations will be there my training
will be there with all the logs if I
want to check something anything I do
after training like playing with with
the trained model eyeballing that it's
actually recognizing my animals all that
will be there as well so let's see now
it's opening and here we go so if I
scroll down my exploratory data analysis
is here I see my classes I see my
training data with the bounding boxes I
can make sure I didn't screw up my image
resizing and throw my bounding boxes off
I have my training cell I have of course
all the training logs here at the end I
can check that this whole training so
full rest at 50 backed Retina net
trained on three hundred thousand images
on a TPU v3 took 28 minutes and 50
seconds to train and of course you want
to know how good it is so let's see on a
couple of images here I'm showing you
evaluation images so on ever images in
the white outline you have the ground
truth
and you see this fox pretty good it did
the elephant's I'm not cherry picking my
my examples so you will see false
detection here there is no person and
the chimp is not a bear but the zebra
are ok the the polar bear is nice here
it got the leopard the tiger a little
bit of an arrow on the tiger the baby
pandas are hard it doesn't have a lot of
babies in the data set so it got one I'm
actually quite happy about that in this
fairly busy scene it sees horses and
cattles so that's that's quite nice as
well what else the way I have I have a
Jaguar here nobody's complaining hey
this Jaguar is actually a leopard ok III
didn't know the difference either before
I started working with this data set we
can forgive this on stage built model
for not spotting that it gives me Snow
Leopard air lion and so on so no
actually not bad at all
for something that we trained on stage
he here in less than 30 minutes
this was fearing a way of taking any
payload but notebook friendly and
launched it as a job
just a little productivity tool for you
data scientists you say you say where
you want to deploy you say what hardware
architecture you want this can be a
whole cluster and you say what you want
to deploy and you go
thank you - so Nick we have good
hardware we have good software we have a
nice working environment with notebooks
and jobs it's time to get the work done
yeah it seems that we are short on time
so let's get stuff done and just a small
coincidence here GSD it means also for
our company gigs our solution delivery
engine set of process that we built to
make it happen
and don't mix it with SGD which is
stochastic gradient descent so by having
access to GPUs and fairing we were able
to explore a lot of different hyper
parameters train many instances of our
narrow nets and maybe you can tell us
where you started from
yeah I will cover it ok as we go so as
you can see we show some interesting
variations here among all the
experiments that we did first thing to
highlight here is that we started from
the retina net implementation not from
the tensorflow
official rep demise for GPU it was just
the some other implementation of retina
net and it took us about three days to
train this model on GPU I would not say
that the order or two orders of
magnitude speed-up is the thing that we
want to communicate to you here thanks
to TP use because that model you told me
it had some issues you did a little bit
of investigation you had to train it as
at the batch size of - right yeah there
was a problem with the batch size the
there was a problem because of the
memory limits and we only stick with
vege sizes of - and also I want to say
that when we were delivering to the
customer we had to deliver over 20
different models and we had like very
aggressive timeline so we shifted to
production and decided that we will get
back to it during the second iteration
of the product and after that we
partnered with Google to start using TP
use
for the process so on GPU so the thing
that we want to highlight here it took
us about two hundred dollars and three
days to train a model of comparable
quality that we were able to get with
CPUs for seven dollars so that's a
that's a great value and obviously
written Annette optimized for TPU is a
great contribution to that number the
second thing that we want to highlight
is the best model that we got it is the
highest ever accuracy in MIP one of the
metrics that is used for evaluation of
the quality of the object detector we
use our favorite TPU v3 image size 512
and we trained it for 10 epics
while in the past we I think did 3 or 5
epochs only just because of the time
limitations we didn't have the luxury to
train our neural nets and wait until all
the experiments finish until we find
great combination of hyper parameters
and here you see that with DPS we were
able to Train it in two hours to get
this quality so that's that's a win and
we are super excited to show you this
model here on stage as well this is the
model is currently integrated into the
product and it's serving real customers
so let's see this one here in my
notebook I have a little utility oops
please go up where I can so let me
restart restart this from the beginning
and instead of training I will just say
please reload from a trained model
it's a 512 pixel model and I will simply
skip the training part and go directly
to inference here we go so now the model
is it will get there in this it's
reloading its reloading from a saved
model and then again I will be getting
random images not cherry-picking
anything random images from my eval data
set now it's computing the the boxes on
those images and you see the chimp
perfect the polar bear is perfect you're
still having a white the ground truth on
this eval data set what else do we have
that's probably not arrayed looks like a
shark we have a gorilla here the wolf
I'm not sure but the Komodo dragon is
perfect let's see on these more
challenging images leopard and Jaguar
and this time in this busy cowboy scene
it actually sees the little dog here and
yes my favorites
it got both pandas rights design Kaiser
eccentric metrics make sure that two
pandas are detectable so this was the
model and I think what I what we wanted
to highlight is that speed velocity of
your data science team is not just for
their comfort it's for the cost of what
it what you pay but also you can
experiment more and get better results
and you actually did a even more
experimentation yeah more
experimentation it's it's how to use TP
use for inference and by default we
already know that TP use are very
powerful machines and they expect big
batches while when we serve models in
production the typical workflow or load
pattern is to have one image at a time
hits API endpoint we do the processing
and so on and if we use TP use in that
scenario probably that will not fully
utilize the power of tbo we thought
about some other workflow that will
benefit from TP use and actually we
found this workflow in the project it's
not the theoretical workflow or just
workflow for this presentation in our
case we had a data set of over 100
million images and we had to build a
visual search solution on top of that
data set so what we did we had a pre
trained neural net we passed all images
through this neural nets to generate
embeddings then we index that data set
of vectors using the face package and
then we got the nearest neighbor
approximate search built in the entire
stack supports visual search
for that purpose we again here's TPU v3
and as you can see on the slide it is
the fastest and the cheapest alternative
to make sure that we can complete this
very complex massive indexing job job
that combines the generation of
embeddings and supporting the visual
search Thank You Nick so we talked to
you about building a neural networks
optimizing them but there is actually a
lot lot more in a full-blown project
than that this is kind of the workflow
you're using well yeah this is the
workflow that we used to develop for the
enterprise and it's very different from
having a Jupiter notebook on a laptop or
even connected to the cloud machine we
have the environment where our data
scientists do training and
experimentation then we upgraded to the
environment where we dam or our models
to the customer every two weeks just
following their child iterations and we
have some representation of the customer
I will not you know start pointing then
we upgrade our models into the
environment where we do the first
integration of machine learning with the
web mobile part of the product this is
where we do the testing at the program
level and then we start already moving
to the client environment where we have
up staging and app production and so
what I see here is that you need to move
all those workloads between yourselves
and also between you and the client yeah
it's very critical for gigster because
we first build it using our talent
network and then we have to hand our
code to the client and also make sure
that they can maintain that code base
contribute to that code base moving
forward I think you have a perfect use
case for work for for cube flow yeah we
are currently looking into cube flow we
are not using it right now but this is
one thing that could help you know us
and you standardize the development of
the pipelines and make it shareable
within your organization and also with
the client organization shareable and
reproducible so just a shout out to cube
flow if you are facing these problems
that is something you can also look up
[Music]